Thank you! I'm the program manager for
the STEM Ambassador Program which is a
research and public engagement program
directed by Dr. Nalini Nadkarni, funded
by the National Science Foundation and
based at the University of Utah. I'm
gonna give an overview of the training
that we've developed in our outcomes
from our first two years of the program.
So I'll start by just saying the public
generally has a high opinion of science
science as a profession and this there's
a view that scientists are making a
valuable contribution to society. So
scientists are in a good position to
address the challenge of expanding the
reach of public engagement activities;
however, they need training to identify
appropriate audiences and venue for
engagement and in going beyond solely
transmitting science not knowledge
content to instead facilitate a dialogue.
So our research team created STEM app to
build relationships for open-minded
exchange between the public and
scientists. We provide engagement to
science or engagement training to
scientists we refer to as STEM
ambassadors. These are scientists who are seeking to engage with the public
outside of traditional venues. That is
outside of museums, schools, and science
centers and this enables them to connect
with people who might not engage with
science in traditional ways. So we
present the scientist with several
ambassador goals to add several
ambassador objectives to achieve this
overarching STEM app goal of
facilitating open-minded exchange.
These objectives include demonstrating
shared values with members of the public,
revealing that scientists have
identities outside of science that are
respectful of the identities of others,
showing that the scientific community
cares about the public's well-being,
demonstrating a desire to learn from and
with others, and increasing the
accessibility of scientists to the
public and the public to scientists. So
we don't emphasize the objective of
improving science literacy. We found that
many scientists enter the program with a
desire to fulfill this objective already
so we don't discourage this but we
challenge the scientists to achieve one
of these other ambassador objectives in
addition to any knowledge-based
objectives. So self-identity values and
our connection to others influences how
we receive and contextualize information.
So in a recent paper Julie Risien and Martin Storksdieck proposed that
scientists can integrate the many
components of their identity as a
hobbyist, researcher, parent, and so on to
develop an impact identity which will
guide them in
doing engagement activities that they
find fulfilling and rewarding. So STEM
app draws on a scientists impact
identity to establish an authentic
connection with what we call a focal
group or a group gathered around a
shared interest, experience,
characteristic, or circumstance that
resonates with the scientist. So for
example we worked with an urban planner
who's studying water use in landscaping
and one facet of her impact identity
was her passion to connect with people
who face physical barriers to
participating in science in science.
She was also really interested in
engaging those who were involved in
landscaping because she's her research
is concerned with outdoor water use and
landscaping practices. So she identified
inmates in a horticultural career
training program at a county jail as a
focal group who might share an interest
in water use and water wise landscaping
practices but who faced physical
barriers to participating in science and
so she ultimately partnered with the
jail's horticulture program to offer a
water-wise landscaping class to the
inmates.
We found that scientists can draw on
their impact identity to access a huge
diversity of audiences and venues
including adult and youth correctional
facilities, senior centers, cafes, Housing
Authority developments, and rock climbing
walls. Because the ambassadors go to so
many different places we found that
there was a need to develop our training
in such a way that we were imparting
generalizable skills that can be applied
to create targeted programs for each
focal group. So rather than provide
communication training specific to each
group which logistically would have been
really difficult we trained the
scientists to conduct what we call an
immersion visit. So scientists visit the
the focal group venue, they talk with
group representatives, they take notes on
the format and layout of the venue, the
shared values or experiences of the
group, and how the group communicates so
this is really bringing in that kind of
code design element. This visit
really serves to explore the connection
the Ambassador identified when
developing his or her impact identity
and it also serves to inform the design
of their engagement event. So after the
the scientist completes
their immersion visit, they apply a
design thinking process which is a
process that's traditionally applied by
designers to take a user-centered
approach to developing innovative
solutions. So scientists use this design
thinking process to transform their
immersion notes into an engagement activity that's
targeted to the focal group they plan to
work with. They use the notes from their
immersion to develop a guiding statement
that summarizes their observations and
their objectives and then they then use
this statement to brainstorm
communication strategies and engagement
activities that are specific to the
focal group. We then provide science
communication training which is derived
from the portal to the public program to
help the scientists facilitate their
engagement activity. The activities take
many different forms and are specific to
the focal group. They often overlap with
pre-existing gatherings in the group
venue which allows the scientists to
engage with people who might not
frequent informal science learning venues
or make a deliberate effort to go to a
science themed event. So I'll give a
couple examples of what some of these
look like. We had a biologist in our
program who has several science themed
tattoos and she facilitated a tattoo
event at a local coffee shop that was
located right next door to a tattoo
parlor. She invited a tattoo artist from
the neighboring tattoo parlor to come
over and participate in the event and
codesign the event with her so they
were there to share their designs and
she was there to share the science
tattoos that she and her colleagues in
the biology department have. And so in
doing so she was able to reveal that
scientists have an interest in identity
outside of science that is this shared
interest in tattoos. We worked with an
oncologist who studies the cancer genome. She engaged with electricians. She
described the techniques that she uses
to understand biological circuits and
map the cancer genome and then she
invited the electrician's to share the
tools that they use to map complex
electrical systems. So this really gave
her a fresh new way of thinking about
her research and demonstrated that
scientists are willing to learn from
others. We also worked with an atmospheric
scientist who was studying air quality.
He attended a children's festival that
was hosted by a community center serving
a low-income area. He presented a
hands-on activity and shared his work to
address Salt Lake's air quality problem
and in doing so was you know
demonstrating that scientists are
working on relevant community issues and
care about the community's well-being.
So since we began in 2016 we've trained 46
scientists who have engaged roughly
nineteen hundred people through over a
hundred different engagement events in
40 unique venues.
The majority of our trainings were
through an in-person workshop series, so
4 workshops occurring over several
weeks and then we worked with the
scientists to actually facilitate their
engagement activity and we're now
exploring an online format with a cohort
of eight scientists who were scattered
around the country and institutions
outside of the University of Utah. Our
participant response has generally been
positive. Over 90% of the participants
felt the scientist did a good job
communicating and tried to make the
interaction positive and survey and
interview data from our first two
cohorts have revealed that the
scientists are finding their
participation in the program to be
valuable as well. We observed an increase
in self assess science communication
confidence and ambassadors also
indicated that their participation in
the program has piqued their interest in
engaging with new groups in the future.
So we're finding that the process of
developing one's impact identity has
helped the ambassadors to realize new
engagement venues and opportunities. Many
scientists, 71% of the scientists that
entered our program, identified
opportunities a lack of opportunities
and a lack of venues as a barrier to
their participation in public engagement.
We saw this go down to 29 percent upon
completion of the training. So to
summarize we've had success in guiding
scientists and developing their impact
identity and this has been a
collaborative effort of Nalini Nadkarni
at the University of Utah, Shelly Goldman
at Stanford University, Dennis Schatz at the
Pacific Science Center, Sue Allen at the
Maine Mathematics and Science Alliance,
and Becky Menlove at the Natural
History Museum of Utah. We are also
working with an external evaluator at
Inverness Research and we're now really
working to explore strategies to sustain
and scale up this program. So I look
forward to sharing ideas with all of you
throughout the meeting and learning how
others have approached this challenge.
Thanks!
There we go. I'm curious have you had any
scientists where it was hard to find
their impact identity or where you had
to work a lot to figure out what that group would be?
Yes, so we started by
doing one-on-one interviews with the
scientists to come up with their impact
identity and initially we really didn't
have a set framework for these
interviews and so for some scientists
they would come in and say well I'm
studying such an obscure thing, I don't
know who would be interested in this or
how I can connect and so what we started
doing was really breaking down the key
elements of who the scientist is and
what they do. So we we developed an
exercise where we asked them a series of
interview questions and then have them
generate these sticky notes with key
words related to their responses to the
questions and so the sticky notes can
include the scientist's hobby, you know
maybe they're a skier, a mountain biker,
and then also their research for their
microbiologist or physicist and then we
look at all of these keywords together
and use those two to brainstorm
potential connections. And now that
we've developed that exercise and now
that we have a few examples of what
previous scientists have done so we're
creating kind of a database on our
website of what different biologists
have done, what different physicists have
done, we found that that process is
becoming a little bit easier
Okay so your program sounds super awesome!
You mentioned scaling up. Is this the
kind of thing that you would want to be
available like for free for other
scientists in other parts of the country
or just at your university. Now so we're
really interested in reaching scientists
in other parts of the country. We've been
piloting an online format which is
consisting right now of a series of
webinars and trainings for scientists. We
are finding though that there's a really
valuable in-person component to the
program so we're playing around with
some ideas right now of how
might you know work with scientists
remotely but still provide them with
that in-person support or mentorship. But
yeah we're looking to engage with
scientists around the country.